you mentioned earlier that one of the
reasons why maybe these conversations
are not being had because many
industries would take a big hit and so
to control it I think it's a quote you
gave about when Tesla was able to build
a car without an engine or without a
battery and I think he was talking to an
entrepreneur at the time I don't know if
it was Edison or a Ford who was that he
was talking he was talking to JP Morgan
was talking to jokah Tesla Tesla
actually had a prototype car that was
fully an energy out of the environment
and he didn't really understand what
that was we do now it's called
zero-point energy or quantum vacuum
energy but basically just for people who
are non-scientific it not scientists if
you visualize a coffee cup the amount of
space inside that cup has enough energy
to boil off all the oceans of the planet
in its potential and it's called the
zero-point energy field is being
quantified it was in academic papers in
the 50s so professor Casimir Casimir
effect but Tesla Stubb won't stumbled
across this back way back early 20s I
believe maybe before but JP Morgan said
look if we can't put a meter on it we
don't want it so Tesla died a very
bitter man I always joked that Elon Musk
doesn't have a Tesla that he's
manufacturing he has a musk and the
reason I say that to her jokingly is
that of true Tesla would never have to
be plugged into the grid it would be
pulling energy out of this energy this
state of energy that's around us through
very high voltage systems they're called
V H V very high voltage systems that
create an opening into that energy field
and Tesla did enough experimentation
with these sort of very high voltage
systems at certain resonant frequencies
cycles per second Hertz that he broke
that he broke into that area of science
but no one wanted it to come out
now you know fast-forward a hundred
years later we're still burning gasoline
in engines and rocket fuel and Jets and
that's a tragedy for the human race but
it's a tragedy for the planet and it's a
tragedy for our children and my nine
grandchildren so my concern is you know
the future the past is the past but we
have to figure out how to catch up I
sort of back to the future we you know
it's like those that cartoon show the
Jetsons
when they showed people flying around in
these cars when that cartoon was made
those technologies were already
developed going back to what you said
about Free Press
uh you were mentioning the fact that we
think we have a free press what we don't
were you alluding to a project
Mockingbird yes of course project
Mockingbird and there are others that
existed where for example a
constitutional attorney Daniel Sheehan
that's in this new documentary Close
Encounters of the fifth kind he states
that when he was representing the New
York Times in the Pentagon Papers
scandal back in the 70s during the
Vietnam War he saw a document that
listed it listed 42 different people who
were senior national security editors at
major media who were also dual-purpose
on the payroll the CIA and he thought
this was a very significant thing in
terms of freedom of the press and
independence of the press and but nobody
would let that story get reported
because it's it's scandalously corrupt
because the the Free Press and the
Fourth Estate is one of the pillars of a
democracy and that sort of gives like
it'll get sort of a makes a mock project
Maquis murder and they made a mockery of
that and then you know in my own
adventures back in the 90s I was meeting
with Bob Schwartz in New York he was on
the board of time-life which became AOL
Time Warner blah blah blah and you know
he was an older gentleman who had you
know good
with Mike Wallace at 60 minutes and
what-have-you and I was with him at a
gathering in New York I was doing a
briefing for a lot of the New York I
hate to use the word elites but you know
leaders the so-called New York 100 and
when I was at this meeting he turned to
me he says you know the Fourth Estate is
dead I said what do you mean he says
were scribes taking dictation from the
right hand of the king he says we don't
have a Fourth Estate there is no free
press in the United States on the things
that really matter and then he told me
this story
mr. Schwartz told me the story of his
friend Mike Wallace of 60 minutes was
given some documents about these UFO
covert programs and Mike Wallace wanted
to do the story and CBS the 60 Minutes
say you will not do this story and and
Mike Wallace went into a very deep
depression over this that he later
admitted to the public that he was very
depressed but he and and he said on
Larry King I had been on Larry King
around this time and he said on Larry
King Live which was a post on CNN back
in the old days and he said I'm a fraud
and and Larry said what do you mean
you're a fraud to Mike Wallace and he
wouldn't go into the details but this is
the back story Bob Schwartz told me look
you know he was devastated that the
biggest story that would have been ever
in investigative journalism CBS jumped
in and killed it and wouldn't let it be
broadcast or even pursued on 60 minutes
which of course at that time was the
blue-chip investigative reporting you
know news magazine on network television
so that's one of the this is something
that's sort of a side issue to what I'm
working on but it's a big part of why
when you turn on your television set
even if you get these leaked Pentagon
videos that came out they re-released
them this past week you probably saw
them on CNN or elsewhere they're not
going to say a we know what these are be
we
where they come from see we figured out
how they work let me give you a date
that's gonna probably curl your toes
October 1954 that was the date we
mastered gravity control now why don't I
mean by gravity control what I mean by
gravity control our high voltage systems
that cause an object to what looks like
levitate or move the way that vehicle
that you saw in that video released by
to the Pentagon this week and they
confirm yes this is real footage and
they released three different videos
what they didn't say because the people
releasing it don't know this because of
the compartmentalization is that there
is an unacknowledged compartmented
program that began studying this in the
40s and 50s and by 1954 had figured out
how those ought things operate so not to
confuse your viewers any more than I
probably already have but so when you
see one of these objects you have to ask
a question is it a classified aerospace
project from the Lockheed skunkworks or
my uncle's company Northern Brahman or
is it interstellar extraterrestrial and
both are out there by the way but no
one's asking the question is it a or B
[Music]